I thought would be appropriate was to
give this subject matter to them because
these uh members of this commission Are
all uh either retired or working Law
Enforcement Officers they deal with
these body warn cameras they're the ones
that are actually wearing in them
processing them and they're able to talk
with their uh Brethren from around the
country to find out and discuss what are
good practices what are the best
practices so uh that's exactly what this
piece of legislation does it directs
them to uh come up with a report um
hopefully um they will do that and then
we could meet uh bring together the
parties and have uh some legislation
hopefully in the fall so uh at that
point I will conclude my testimony and
thank you very much Mr chairman did we
um Did we tell our colleagues at the at
the commission we would be doing this to
them um I did in fact I talked with
director skippa because he had asked me
about a fiscal note so you will see that
there is a fiscal note here it does
spend some money because they're going
to be issuing a report but they know
thank you any questions for Senator
I represent
M just to clarify the the leak
commission uh that we're talking about
is a a different leak commission than
the one that was established by Governor
sonunu a few years ago yes it is and
this and the leak commission that we're
that we're actually talking about uh is
the law enforcement accreditation
commission and that that that's why it's
all law enforcement officers or former
law enforcement officers
follow their their goal is to create a
standard Statewide for um state law
enforcement agencies to achieve in order
to um get accredited by the state agency
so they're setting best practices across
the state yeah follow up yeah
um part of part of the issue with with
body cams is there there has been push
back and we heard some of this on a
similar bill I think it was HB uh 1021
um that there are times when uh police
officers may not have their cameras
turned on they may cut the audio at
certain points and one of the things
that came up is you know should we be
more directive about things like when
audio is cut and when audio isn't cut um
one thing that just strikes me as as a
concern uh is that we get those concerns
you know from citizens and people who've
had encounters with law enforcement and
if we have a group made up exclusively
of Law Enforcement Officers that's
looking to kind of take our legislation
around body camps to the next level I'm
just wondering if we're getting the kind
all of the input uh that we really need
to get on the issue um thank you very
much for the comment um the chair is ex
correct I mean these are made up of
people that are either retired or
they're working in law enforcement um
one of the things we discovered um and
on a commission that I was working on a
few years ago that there wasn't
standardization across the board for
every Department everyone would do
something a little differently and so we
charged this board to come up with
standards that's why the chair of
Judiciary and the chair of Criminal
Justice is on this particular committee
um they're the ones that are out there
working every day with these cameras
they're the ones that you know know what
the standards quite frankly should be
and so we're looking to get advice from
them we also will have the County
attorneys um involved but we want to get
the report first and get a reaction and
see what they have to say um and we'll
bring everybody together and we'll file
legislation this is not going to be done
in a vacuum um this is a very public
process I'm sure people are going to be
watching the these meetings that we go
to are open to the public so if citizens
are concerned about what they're
discussing they're more than welcome
they even have a public comment uh time
for the public to come in and talk so um
I don't see it as a problem there's
plenty of opportunity for people to be
involved but this is to get their
perspective on their be best practices
because we're going to take that and it
will be something that will go into this
new manual that's been created about
best practices and creating standards
across the state so it shouldn't matter
if you got stopped in conquered you got
stopped in Salem or you got stopped in
Berlin the standard will be the
same you're welcome and and and most
importantly this would result in
legislation where there'd be a public
hearing and we'd get the same feedback
we heard already and everyone would have
the opportunity to weigh in
representative s
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question Senator um I'm just
curious because not every Police
Department in the state requires body
worn cameras and so I'm I'm curious
whether I know that's not specifically
identified in your um in your bill but I
just wasn't sure if there was an impact
associated with where you're talking
about trying to make sure that it's fair
treatment you know Equitable treatment
Statewide how the impact of some towns
having and some not how that relates
well thank you for the question question
the towns that don't have them this
isn't going to impact them at all where
it will impact them is if they decide
they want to have body worn cameras and
now these are the standards that they
must adhere to um I I think hopefully
that answers your question I mean I'm I
am not going to micromanage um in this
legislation and say every police officer
in the state has to wear them that is a
local decision that they're going to
make um it as you can imagine it's
extremely
expensive and um if we mandated it we'd
have to pay for it under article 21A so
I don't see that happening all the only
thing I see happening is if a if a
department that does not use these
cameras decide they want to these are
the standards they have to adhere to
you're
welcome represent
Newman thank could could you comment on
as you were doing your preparation for
this and and came to the idea that it
should be what you have in the bill
right now what kind of feedback you got
if any about the current law and how was
that helpful to come up with that I'm
just curious how it's working the one
that's in effect now thank you very much
um I think the one that we have now it's
kind of like a skeletal frame that
really needs to be fleshed out and this
is what this bill attempted to do and
there there were groups of people that
came in that said it went too far and
there were groups of people that came in
and said it was didn't go far enough and
so that's why I thought you know let's
talk to the people who really do this
every day the members of the commission
are from all over the state so we're
just not going to get the big cities
we're going to get the small towns as
well so I um they're serious about doing
this work and so I would like to
publicly thank them for willing to do
this but um I just think it needs to be
fleshed out more um and we'll see what
they come up
with thank you that's
helpful and every so often Federal grant
money appears and if a department
doesn't have a standard to adhere to it
makes it difficult for them to be able
to apply for it and and get it and put
it into use so having a having this made
standardized um after we get the
feedback and put it into legislation
will help departments who can't
necessarily afford it based on their tax
money but could if they had grant money
to do so um any further questions seeing
none thank you for your testimony thank
you very much Mr chairman anybody
else chair calls attorney Steve Enders
s I'll come up with attorney
Andrew good morning my name is Steven
andw I'm an assistant County attorney in
maram County with me is Paul Halverson
who is the maram County Attorney both of
us have been prosecutors for over 20
years um body warn cameras are actually
a really fascinating subject and uh New
Hampshire has a body warn camera statute
RSA 105 D2 and when you look at that
statute you can break it down
essentially into two major parts the
first part is the creation of the body
warant camera recording by law
enforcemen out in the field and then the
second part of that statute deals with
handling of body warn recordings once
they're already
made that that second part of the
statute where it talks about handling a
body warn camera recordings has sort of
four subsections as I read it talks
about a Prohibition on copying altering
or Distributing the body warn camera
talks about guidelines for accessing
body warn cameras it talks about
guidelines for storage of body warn
cameras and then there's requirements
related to the destruction or retention
of body warn camera
recordings the the difficulty with the
way the current statute is written is it
doesn't really take into account any way
for those camera recordings to be used
during the discovery process in in
criminal
prosecution um if you read the statute
literally it says no person shall copy
Cy body warn camera
recordings normally um discover is
fairly liberal in New Hampshire where if
we have something as the prosecution we
provide it to the defense makes it
difficult if the police department has a
body warant camera recording are they
allowed to copy it and give it to the
prosecution and are we subsequently
allowed to then copy it and give it to
the
defense and if we do in fact copy it and
give it to the defense it brings up
questions about Act access storage and
retention of those body warn camera
recordings that again are all addressed
in 105 D2 but once you start making a
copy and giving it to a third party it
it's out of our hands with with what
happens with it it's interesting that
when you think of body warn cameras
there's there's actually a lot of
information on bodyw warn cameras
there's not just police officers doing
things there's uh non-law Enforcement
Officers civilians in the background
there's you know people saying things to
the police giving information to the
police interviews may occur in people's
homes um you may end up seeing the
interior of a person's home which you
know might not be something that you
want to necessarily give to a criminal
defendant with without any restriction
so we attempted to address that and uh
proposed Senate Bill
362 and I think this is a good first
step um you know obviously I would I
would have preferred to have seen
something comprehensive past but I
certainly understand sending it to to
the law enforcement accreditation
commission to take a look at makes sense
um and at least in my mind what this is
looking at isn't
necessarily the creation of those body
warn cameras in the field but is looking
at the issues raised by copying
distribution and use in uh in the
discovery process in in prosecution so
I'm obviously happy to answer a question
I'm not sure if attor H is anything to
add if I could I'm having d didn't we
just discuss this like a month ago two
months ago is there another bill that
came through the house that's in the
Senate now that does this there was a
bill that came through the house that I
think was inexpedient to legislate oh
okay okay
in addition to what attorney Andress
said the the big issue one of the big
issues I see it is uh is privacy privacy
for um the individuals that are on the
videotape you're seeing them at their
worst day they may be having U mental
health issues they may be having uh um
may be a victim of of a crime and
frankly there needs to be some control
on the distribution of that body Waring
camera video uh my worst nightmare uh as
far as far as body Waring cameras go is
seeing some of the body Waring cameras
that I see on on YouTube basically uh
and that there should be some protection
in place that keeps that from from
happening um and I can representative
you asked a question about uh input from
uh non-law enforcement when I was
listening to your question uh I was
thinking about the conversations that
I've had with uh other County attorneys
local police departments as well as
director skippa over at the police
standards and and training that's not
lost on on any of us um and it's not
lost on any of of the discussions that
that we've had uh it's been um it's been
a point of discussion routinely uh about
what the average person thinks ought to
happen with body Waring cameras and the
materials and frankly I'll Circle back
to what I just said a moment ago that
the I think the average person would
expect that there would be some prote
ctions for body War camera video when it
shows the inside of their house when it
shows them having a mental health crisis
when it shows their minor son or
daughter as a victim uh when it shows an
interview that may include personal data
name date of birth place of birth items
such as that uh that may be recorded
when a uh when a police officer does a
uh interview um I've seen examples of
Bing Waring cameras that uh recorded a
um uh a full U strip search pursuant to
a search warrant of an individual when
they were looking for for drugs frankly
that video should have some protection
to it because there's full frontal
nudity of that individual um those are
the type of things that we need to to
protect against and uh when this um Bill
uh was making its way over to the house
I actually talked to director skippa
about this and uh he and
I think we see the the the benefit of
this going to the commission to look at
it in totto and try to make things
better the bill that was written at
govern's body warn cameras uh now is a
very tight Bill and what I mean by that
is there are a lot of restrictions but
where it loses its tightness is once
that body warant camera material leaves
the possession of the state then it
loses all of those protections it loses
the storage um and uh there have been
arguments um uh made that once it
becomes part of Discovery to a defendant
that they can just willy-nilly release
it and uh frankly that's that's the
nightmare of every victim of crime and
that's the thing we have to protect
against so hopefully the leak uh folks
can help out with that and uh get back a
fairly comprehensive um Amendment for uh
um for next
session thank you any questions
representative
Newman I just happen to look at the law
that you talked about copying and that
they can't do that and and the L it says
no person but then it's immediately
followed by
um it says no person including without
limitation officers so does that mean
they cannot do that can't it sounds like
they can't do anything with it as I read
it no person can copy body warn camera
video but I I can tell you it's
routinely happening in New Hampshire
because it's being provided as Discovery
in criminal cases but it sounds like
they added that just to emphasize it and
I can tell you from from my position as
as County attorney I need to tell the
police departments that they have to
follow the law and I follow it the way
you the way your legis the way our
legislators wrote it and there's a no
person shall copy including without
limitation it lists everybody within
there and we've had to rely on uh
attorney endis has been the lead person
doing some litigation we've to rely on
court orders to allow us to comply with
our Discovery requirements to keep the
items private that should be private
with a protective order and still
maintain our meet our obligations for
for Discovery and and I mean I can tell
you that language no person including
law enforcement actually comes from the
international Chiefs of police model
policy the model policy says no officer
shall copy which made sense that the
rank and officers cannot copy cannot
cannot do anything to their body warant
camera video but the original language
left an opening for their supervisors to
copy it through the discovery process
and that was amended by the house to get
rid of only officers and it it added no
person including officers um shall copy
it just follow up follow up it sound
sounds like that this is an issue that's
ongoing so this study is important and
it has to be done in a timely manner
it's definitely definitely ongoing we
see it routinely okay thank you so
attorney Enders basically every case
that you prosecute that has a body War
camera video you're having to request a
protective order and an order to copy it
so initially we were fing we were
litigating it in in almost every case
saying judge we can't copy this the
statute says no copying uh we did get an
order from one of our judges who says
that implicit within 105 D2 is the
ability to copy it and provide it in
Discovery and indicated but a protective
order would be appropriate we then ended
up litigating in a number of cases what
an appropriate protective order would be
um based on some of the rulings we got
we sat down with the public defender
office in in maram county and said let's
write up up an agreement for a
protective order that we can both live
with so that we don't have to bother the
court in every single case but if we
have cases where people aren't willing
to sign sort of our standard protective
agreement we'll litigate it in every
case it's worthwhile to note too that
one of the judges in the early part of
the litigation commented um that
legislative action about this uh would
be appreciated I'm paraphrasing what the
judge said but that was in one of the
orders that was issued by the superior
court that you know perhaps the
legislature wants to look at this and
that's what drove our contact with
Senator Carson and got us to where we
are
today thank you thank
you chair calls Tom DEA
good morning excuse me uh for the record
Tom D Roa uh uh be fresh Consulting I'm
here on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
I put neutral down because there's not
much now that this bill has been uh
amended to that deals necessarily with
uh criminality in in the law but we
worked with the County attorneys and
others uh
initially in crafting this uh
legislation and I maybe I put neutral
probably should maybe still put a POS
because when we look at this we still
think that as we've heard a little bit
this morning it should go through more
of a traditional legislative study
process where we bring more than just
law enforcement together and bring
everybody in to study it so we can hear
from everybody and work on something and
maybe bring something forward that uh
goes through a more traditional process
and helps all sides uh come together
where we came to a bit of an impass uh
and earlier this year and this is what's
before you now so just wanted to put
that on the record uh would be happy to
take any questions back to the
association if there are
any I would just comment that um
whatever comes out of the commission is
going to come forward as a normal piece
of legislation that would then bring
everybody else to the table so this is
really a first step before we get to
what you said should happen is going to
happen
eventually if you follow what I mean
that
yeah I mean right our our we would love
to see this a study commission or study
committee with you know members of the
public and legislators as weal and that
if that's what you know leak ultimately
decides then okay but U again we'd like
to see that that Stu there as well so I
appreciate that thank you seeing no
questions thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill who hasn't done so seeing
none I hereby close public hearing on
house Senate Bill
362 10 minutes
what the
heck
e
e e
invite Senator Whitley to interest
Bill thank you Mr chair uh and good
morning members of the committee for the
record my name is Becky Whitley I'm
honored in uh to represent New Hampshire
Senate District 15 which you all are all
sitting in which includes the wonderful
communities of conquered bow and
hopkington so today I'm honored to
introduce Senate Bill
508 this bill was developed in
collaboration with many instate
stakeholders and the Council of state
government um Justice Center so as many
of these committee me of you committee
members know CSG the Justice Center at
CSG has been working extensively in New
Hampshire uh in collaboration with many
of the stakeholders to study and address
the high and persistent utilization of
Public Health and County Jail Resources
by people with mental illness and
substance use disorders uh this work by
the CSG Justice Center was initiated
from the governor's advisory Commission
on mental illness and the correction
system so in particular this bill will
address the lack of care coordination
and validated screening tools for those
with Behavioral Health needs in our
County jails it will do so by ensuring
jail contractors in New Hampshire will
be using validated screening tools for
substance use disorders and mental
health disorders for those hous in our
jails additionally to encourage warm
handoffs from incarceration to Community
Jail superintendent will under the bill
you have before you establish a process
for our cmhc or Community Mental Health
Centers for those Personnel who meet
security criteria to connect with those
who are incarcerated
pre-release the use of validated
screening tools will help bring all New
Hampshire County jails to best practice
standards which of course I think we
should all be aiming for and ensure that
those who are housed are properly
screened for sub subsequent assessment
or treat treatment if needed again an
important um way to present uh to get
folks connected to treatment the
development of a process for cmhc
personnel to conduct jail inreach will
help provide resources and connections
sooner to those being released to
support of course successful re-entry
increase the likelihood of Engagement
with treatment and then ultimately
reduce recidivism thank you very much
for your consideration of this bill I'm
happy to take any questions I'll defer
more sort of technical questions about
um the process to folks behind me the
providers and our experts um I do uh
have an amendment here um that I will
let the folks from new Futures discuss
but I'm fully supportive of this um I am
in the middle of committee so my
apologies if I need to run back to HHS
um we are both executing bills in two of
my committees today so um I need to be
at three places at once so happy to take
any questions and thanks for your
consideration
see no questions thank you okay thank
you very
much chair recognize Holly Stevens
chairman Roy and members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens I'm
the director of public policy at Nami
New Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through education support and
advocacy
on behalf of Nami New Hampshire I am
here today in support of Senate Bill
508 people with mental illness deserve
help not handcuffs yet people with
mental illness are over represented in
our state's jails and
prisons the data regarding the
intersection of Criminal Justice and
mental health both locally and
nationally is spotty at best however it
is estimated that two in five people who
are incarcerated have a mental illness
that's 30 7% in state and federal
prisons and 44% in local
jails in addition 66% of women in prison
reported having a history of mental
illness uh according to a recent Union
Leader article more than half of the
inmates at the prisons in New Hampshire
have a mental illness have excuse me
have a mental health
diagnosis the number is even higher
among women
the the numberers is even higher among
women inmates it's
67% um who were prescribed to
psychiatric
medication um the article goes on to
state that in Rockingham ham County 51%
of the 170 people residing in their jail
required an active treatment plan for a
mental health
diagnosis and as you heard Senator W
Whitley talk about the um CSG um
involvement in New Hampshire I also
included some of the slides from the
report that they did um that I
referenced in my testimony I thought
that might be helpful for you to have
those and if anybody is interested in
having the full 91 page report I'm happy
to email that to you but I didn't want
to clog up your email boxes without um
knowing that it's something that you
wanted to
read starting in March of 2022 the staff
from the Cs G Justice Center supported
the governor's Commission on mental
health and correction system in
actualizing two goals one of which was
improving criminal justice and public
health outcomes for people in New
Hampshire with behavioral health
conditions who use the jail systems at
high
rates CSG found that nearly half of the
individuals that entered the New
Hampshire jails from 2019 to 2021 were
matched with Medicaid claims and they
used the Medicaid Claim data um in order
to do some investigation
on substance use um disorders and mental
health and they they found that
93% of the category that they call high
utilizers of jail Services were on
Medicaid and had at least one Behavioral
Health
claim additionally of the high
utilizers 73% had at least um one Mental
Health primary
diagnosis 84% had at at least one
substance use disorder primary diagnosis
and 66% had co-occurring
disorders high utilizers of jail
Services were also more likely to have a
serious mental illness more were more
likely to have suicidal ideation suicide
attempts or intentional self harm and
one of the recommendations that came out
of this study was to increase jail
Behavioral Health and re-entry
Services collectively it cost New
Hampshire jails an average of 26 million
to incarcerate people for the high just
the High
utilizers um when individuals with
mental illness receive the right
services at the right place at the right
time fewer folks will end up being
repeatedly incarcerated thus costing the
New Hampshire County is much less in
jail costs and we know that um Senator
Whitley talked about the warm handoffs
we know that when um
somebody um is connected with
Services right before they re-enter into
the Community if there's a warm handoff
into the community rather than just
giving them a name of somebody to
call that they're more successful with
treatment and they're less likely to uh
be reincarceration after the
fact so we need to reduce criminal
justice involvement and increase
investments in mental health care even
while individuals are incarcerated
Senate Bill 508 which is closely related
to one of the CSG study recommendations
would ensure with proper screening tools
that individuals receive the proper care
while in New Hampshire jails the bill
also ensures continuity of care and
could reduce recidivism rates by
allowing Community providers into the
jails to coordinate those Services as I
mentioned before somebody re-enters into
the community and for those reasons uh
Nami New Hampshire urges the committee
to support this bill and vote it ought
to pass and I will answer any questions
if anybody has any
seeing no question representative
Muse I I did have one question and you
may or may not be the the right person
to uh to answer this but what exactly is
a validated screening tool and who does
the
validation there's screening tools that
are evidencebased um I don't know who
does the
validation um but they're standardized
training tools that are used throughout
the the uh mental health um system thank
you so no further questions thank you
thank
you chair calls Jake Barry
good morning Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is Jake
Barry I'm the vice president of policy
at new Futures as many of you know new
Futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
Health policy and advocacy organization
we've been working for more than 25
years to help address substance misuse
and addiction in our state uh I don't
want to repeat too much of what's been
said Miss uh Miss Stevens from my friend
Miss Stevens from Nami uh uh used a lot
of my talking points but I do want to
stress our strong support for this bill
as well as the support of stakeholders
across the treatment and Recovery
community in addition to my own written
testimony I've shared with you copy of a
joint letter from Health from leading
Health Care substance use mental health
treatment and Recovery uh organizations
around our state all of whom believe
that this bill will help to increase
access to treatment services for
individuals uh in our Cor in our County
correctional system uh again miss Ste
Miss Stevens made the case that you know
a vast majority of of individuals
especially High utilizers in our uh in
our County jails have been shown to have
either a diagnosis substance use
disorder or or uh mental health
diagnosed mental health condition or
both uh these are people who need uh
treatment not they need to be treated
not to be punished uh an investment in
their in their treatment and their
recovery is an investment not just in
these individuals but in our counties as
a whole knowing that the the cost that
our uh uh that our our County Jail
facilities and ultimately our County
taxpayers have to bear to to keep them
incarcerated again as um as Miss Steven
stated uh the CSG study showed that it
cost about $6.5 million to house
utilizers between 2019 and 2021 about
half of this was reimbursed by Medicaid
leaving our jails and our County
taxpayers on the hook for the remaining
uh $30 million uh bills such as this
which uh uh which increase uh access to
treatment through validated screening
tools and uh through expanding the
workforce of folks who were able to come
Behind the Walls to provide Services um
this will reduce recidivism and
ultimately uh save taxpayer dollars
uh uh Senator Whitley mentioned the uh
the amendment that that that she's
putting forward uh this is a very minor
Amendment there was a concern expressed
by folks in our treat our recovery
Community about an unintended
consequence many of them there are
currently Arrangements between many
recovery centers or recovery Community
organizations and the county jails in
which uh certified community sorry
Community Support Recovery workers are
already uh serving behind the walls are
already helping to provide care
coordination Services uh they were not
covered in the original language of this
bill so there was concerned that there
would be an unintended consequence of
serving to box out uh csws Community
recovery support workers uh in favor of
um just the the original language which
I think said uh license Community
licensed Community Based treatment
provider so again this is just adding
csws into the language of the bill uh to
to be able to maintain the services that
they are currently providing and
hopefully encourage those kind of
arrangements and other facilities as
well um I I work this I believe the the
county superintendents are comfortable
with this language uh the crsw the Comm
The Recovery Center certainly support it
we had new Futures strongly support it
as well again it really is intended just
to maintain the services that are
currently being provided in some jails
so we hope you'll consider the amendment
pass the bill as amended and I'm happy
to take any questions questions
see none thank you thank
you chair calls Karen
Rosenberg good morning I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center New Hampshire's
protection and advocacy system for
people at disabilities and I'm here to
encourage you to support
s508 um the data that was analyzed and
collected by CSG is really telling and
when we're talking about the high-end
utilizers we're talking about a cohort
that that were analyzed in the couple
years that they collected data um first
of all high jail utilizers were people
who were um who had between four and 72
entrances into our County Jail system
for really lowlevel crimes we're not
talking about violent criminals here
we're talking about people who are Pres
predominantly um being incarcerated for
for things like resisting arrest um I'm
looking my notes here um public nuisance
Criminal Trespass criminal mischief
vandalism disorderly conduct things like
that so um these are folks who as you
also heard disproportionately these
high-end utilizers um of our County Jail
system we don't want them to be we'd
rather have them be where they need to
be in the mental health system right we
don't want our our jails are not really
equipped nor should they be equipped to
provide to be a mental health treatment
center um this bill would actually help
to identify those people appropriately
and help to transition them into
appropriate treatment when they're going
to be living on our streets and
hopefully not returning to jail and
hopefully not living on our streets but
living in housing um so we've got you
know folks who have had really you know
high in cycling highly in and out of our
County Jail system we know that this is
about 2600 people who were the high
utilizers at least during that study and
I Holly Stevens cited a lot of
Statistics one that she didn't cite is
that 57% of those High utilizers about
1340 people were diagnosed with having a
serious mental illness so you know these
are folks who would benefit greatly from
treatment the other um thing that I want
you to keep in mind is that the
Department of Health and Human Services
is in the process of securing um
hopefully they will secure a de what's
called a Medicaid 1115 demonstration
project so one of the things that they
that the state is looking to do is to
get permission from the centers for
Medicaid Medicare Services CMS to be
able to secure Federal matching Medicaid
funds for services that are provided to
people who are incarcerated up to 45
days before they are discharged so you
know there's a federal there's
potentially and I I mean I don't know I
I I'm optimistic I think they're going
to get this demonstration waiver so
there's potential Federal funding for
this and it seems like a win-win it's in
line with the recommendations for the C
from the CSG about you know making sure
that we're assessing people and doing
the soft handoffs and also ensuring that
County Corrections Pro provides access
to the Health Services providers and the
community that will ultimately be
serving these folks um right now the
state can't force a County Correction
Facility to let providers in this bill
take care of security concerns by making
sure that anyone coming into County
corrections to do this you know soft
handoff and connection meets any kind of
security issues and has been thoroughly
screened but it's really but it's really
an important step to making sure that
their access is granted here so we can
get people to where they need to be and
I'm happy to take any
questions thank you
questions
repr thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
um I'm I'm I just wanted to clarify
because I know you're talking about
section 115 which is I'm sorry um the
115 demonstration there's another one in
there um but um what I was under the
impression of is that it it essentially
what we're doing is with the waiver is
to put a pause on people's Medicaid
status um while they're so when we're
talking about 15 days in advance would
Services be covered 15 days in advance
or is this signing up 15 days in advance
45 it would allow the state it's 45 days
in advance so this could apply to people
who are in the state prison system also
it would allow um for providers to build
Medicaid for services that are provided
during that 45-day period because
generally Medicaid law and rules do not
permit um Medicaid coverage of services
that are provided in locked facilities
right thank you so much for that
clarification
welcome you enough for the questions oh
no representative s thank you and thank
you for taking my question um you use
the term serious mental illness could
you just give us an example of what
distinguishes serious mental illness
from um I guess less serious so I I
don't have the rule in front of me but
we have defined that in our state rules
but um to the best of my recollection it
has to do with not just having a
diagnosis of Mental Illness but also
functional impairments that result from
that mental health diagnosis so that
could include things like repeat rep
entries into the criminal justice system
rep repeated hospitalizations due to
mental illness um other kinds of in
inability to um to connect with mental
health services in the community those
are the kinds of um additional
functional impairments that are listed
in our definition of serious mental
illness thank
you see no further questions thank you
thank you so anyone else wishing to
testify in this bill who has not done so
yeah are we
finished no one else yeah I don't know
I'm trying to find out yeah Mr chair I
have a question or a a tutorial that I'd
like to ask Holly Stevens to help us out
if this if my comment is better offline
I'll take that there but maybe the
committee would like to hear it I'll ask
it out loud now and you can decide yeah
and that's this I can't I want to
support all these efforts my question is
this I go to an orthopedic surgeon for
broken arm six weeks later the cast is
off and I'm all right appendix comes out
I'm all right mental health can we do
anything about it really I somebody
who's formed from and lives their life
with
this Affliction handicap whatever you
describe their mental Outlook can
Society do anything effective about that
I'd like to hear what these Pro what the
probability of success is how I I I
don't have a good sense of the landscape
of mental health I guess that's my I
think that your question applies more to
the the mental health that um treatment
that's offered broadly versus just a
screening at the jail which would be a
beginning perhaps so why don't you talk
to her and if it sounds like something
we don't already know we'd be happy to
hear but for now we will um close public
hearing
and we begin at 11:00 with executive
session
e
e e
morning everyone we are going to start
our executive
sessions um the first bill Senate Bill
3:15 um relative to law enforcement
agency reporting information concerning
bias
crimes um we had the public hearing on
this one so it is ready to exact however
I am going to move this one to next
Wednesday morning at 10 o' where we be
having a hearing on a non-gain Amendment
for it so that's moved the next one
Senate Bill 321 relative to the release
of the defendant pening trial and I
recognize who representative uh Murphy
might want to make a motion yeah she
looks like she might want to make a
motion maybe representative M Murray
might make the motion
um I make a motion of interam study on
SB
321 second thank you would you like to
speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chair um I think
that this bill
um has some interactions with our
current bill package which is actually
being heard in the Senate today from my
understanding so I think it's wise for
us to hold on to it for now and see um
what happens with those bills before we
make any other further changes to the
bill statute thank you representative um
Ro you like to speak to a second oh
thank you Mr chairman um our clerk did a
fine job we're just going to inm study
these and uh see what the complete
package looks like when it comes out
from the other side thank you I I would
um Second That by saying that um I I
commend our colleagues in the Senate um
just having a belt in suspenders in case
we weren't able to get our bail package
across the goal line but we did and they
have it now so there's no need of this
so I would urge everyone to interm study
any further
discussion seeing none i' ask the clerk
to call the role the motion on the floor
is interim
study B chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative PR yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative Hill yes
representative
Muse yes representative Rosner yes
representative Bon yes representative
elberger yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes uh the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative sake yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
20 interim study carries any objection
consent seeing none going to go on
consent and I close the executive
session on Senate Bill
321 and I open the executive session on
Senate Bill
424 and I
recognize representative um Muse would
you like to make a motion on this
one
yeah uh Mr chair I recommend not to
pass a second would you like to speak to
your motion
what this what this uh Bill does is it
clears up uh some vagueness in the
current law uh that doesn't provide a
prob uh probation parole officer uh with
legal directions on how to consistently
consider Parolees for a reduction in
time for their maximum sentences uh it
creates an annual audit uh for people
under administrative uh supervision uh
and this is uh the rare bill that
actually came from a productive study
committee so I would urge everyone to
support it thank you I'll speak to my
second um it's important to note that
what this bill does in my reading is
that this isn't really cutting um
people's time in jail short what it's
doing is if they've already earned
parole and they're doing well on parole
it allows their parole to be shortened
so that resources can be allocated to um
other people who may need those
resources more than someone who's
actually thriving in the community and
doing well after they've been released
so I would urge also everyone to support
the out to pass motion
further
discussion seeing none last cler to call
the roll motion on the floor is ought to
pass V chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative PR yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative Hill yes
representative Muse yes representative
Rosner yes representative B
en yes representative elberger yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sing yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 Z ought
to pass carries 20 to zero any objection
consent see n no go on consent I hereby
close the executive session I open the
executive session on Senate Bill
426 and I recognize representative
Manion to make a motion thank you Mr
chair make a motion of a to
pass
second would you like speak to your
motion yes I would thank you uh what
this bill does is it it basically
mirrors the alcohol uh transportation of
alcohol law in New Hampshire this
doesn't prohibit you transporting
marijuana in your car it only says that
if you do it must be in a sealed
container
uh and if it's not sealed in the
original packaging you must transport it
in the furthest point away from you uh
in the vehicle whether it's in the trunk
or the glove box secure uh not in Arms
Reach so it basically mirrors the
Alcohol Law there is a carve out in here
for uh prescription marijuana that's
that will be allowed thank
you thank you um I think there's
important um actually representative
Pratt did you want to speak to your
second no I think this is very important
the alcohol law has been around for a
long time it helps police officers to be
able to enforce the law uh we shouldn't
have be allowing people to drive around
uh using drugs the testimony the other
day from the state police was poly
accidents are up tremendously a lot of
deaths in the in the state of New
Hampshire because of the use of alcohol
and drugs at the same time I think this
will help in that situation thank you
thank you um I think it's important to
note that this is um consistency you
know we have um um laws against alcohol
being open in the car within your reach
we have arm uh laws against um
distracted driving you have to be
handsfree you can't have your phone in
your hand um this is the same type of
thing with marijuana and if you knowe it
treats it as though it's a legal
substance the fact that it says you can
have it but just not within reach it's
already taken that next step that many
of the people in this committee wanted
is to have it recognized as a legal
substance just a year ago or so if you
had it anywhere in a car you were under
arrest now we're taking that step and
saying okay if you have it it certainly
shouldn't be within Arms Reach unless of
course it's your medication it makes
that exemption so I think that this
gives consistency to our impaired um and
distracted driving set of laws and it
also takes a step that many people in
the committee and and and Society wanted
to to say okay we're going to recognize
this as a legal substance and treat it
as such so I I urge everyone to um vote
ought to pass for this thank you for the
discussion I also want to note that um
that the final bill was actually amended
and uh the decision to exclude uh
medical marijuana was part of a
compromise so in the spirit of not
messing up a good compromise from the
other body hint hint um where I am
perfectly fine with this uh and and I
also want to say there are a lot of
people I know that are uh advocating uh
for legalization and for the State uh to
begin actually selling uh uh marijuana
uh commercially um I view this as
something that actually helps the cause
one of the things that we've
consistently heard over the years on
this bill is the fact that we don't have
a law like this uh is is something that
raises a lot of concern for police
officers and raises a lot of concerns
for citizens who are you know just AR
quite sure it's safe to drive on the
road sometimes especially on 420 um so
uh I am 100% behind this bill
thanks representative s thank you Mr
chair I probably should have brought
this up when we were having our hearings
the other day but I my only I I support
the bill I'm curious about in terms of
like some of the enforcement just
knowing that you know with alcohol it's
pretty clear if you have a bottle of
Jack in your car it's easy to see a
bottle of Jack sitting on the seat but
where you know like my kids might be
eating gummy bears that are truly gummy
bears and some else might be eating
gummy bears that are not just Gummy
Bears or where someone might be vaping
in a car which is legal but the contents
of their Vape may or may not you know
may be any sort of substance so I I just
am trying to in my head and maybe this
is a conversation someone will have with
me later because I do support the bill
but I just am trying to figure out how
that's going to work no doubt um it'll
be a difficult one for law enforcement
that may end up getting charged as a
secondary offense after after they've
already had to deal with something else
such as an accident and they find in the
seat you know next to the door that
there was marijana or any number of
circumstances in my opinion that could
rise to that where they would say hey
what is that versus you know a child
eating but that's going to be up to the
officer to build that case as he as he
as he um talks to the operator to to get
that Reasonable Suspicion did you have
your hand raised yes uh representative
sitech I uh voted against this uh in
1991 I'm going to vote against it again
and I don't mind consent
calendar thank you represent Manion
thank you Mr chair so a couple things um
what what this bill basically is going
to accomplish is people not they not
going be people driving around smoking
marijuana while they're driving that's
basically the premise of this bill um
but I can tell you that you need to
articulate that something is marijuana
before you're able to go into someone's
car and sees it uh the same if it was a
bag of marijuana I'd have to say based
on my
experience that that is marijuana in
that bag there's an odor it looks like
marijuana a gummy bear or a vape absent
anything else would not allow an officer
to enter the vehicle and and seize that
property yeah thank you
agreed see no further discussion uh the
motion on the floor is ought to pass I'd
ask cl to call the rooll vice chair
Roose yes representative Pratt yes
Representative scitec no representative
PR
yes representative Janan yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative Hill yes representative
Muse yes representative Rosner yes
representative Balton yes representative
elberger yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative saling yes representative
wheeler yay ch Roy cheral yes um 191 19
to1 motion carries out to pass no
objection to consent it will go on
consent close the executive
session with that I open the executive
session
on um Senate Bill
563 and I recognize myself to make a
motion I moved to
introduce amendment
number 1622 that's been passed to the
committee second
second thank you I'll speak to the
motion um after the public hearing and
um discussing with various members on
both sides of the house um it was
decided that the statute or the bill as
written was extremely broad um in as far
as it almost mandated that um there was
cooperation with Federal immigration on
all the immigration laws it really
didn't discuss um on which particular
ones it was just very Broad and it gave
a lot of people pause what the amendment
does is the amendment mandates only that
local authorities cooperate by honoring
detainers and only if a detainer is
discovered through an investigation or
arrest of a New Hampshire law
first in other words they can't be
investigating immigration status they
can only investigate New Hampshire
crimes and if it pops up a detainer then
they will honor the
detainer um it also
specifically um prohibits New Hampshire
law enforcement from inquiring about um
immigration status which the original
bill I do not believe
did so I believe that this bill um is is
something it's it's another compromise
from what we got and I hope that um
everyone can see their way to support
this compromise would you like to speak
to your second no thank you Mr chairman
you did a great job
discussion yeah um we'll take a we'll
take a recess until 11:30 exactly to
everyone to read this
bill
e
e e
563 I'm going to um I'm going to take a
a privilege here I'm going to read
something into the record that I because
this question is come up often during
this bill we what what exactly what's a
detainer anyway and we've heard talk
that you know these are civil processes
and this is um from the from the ice
website it's called detainer
101 says whenever possible ice Works
closely with local law enforcement
Partners to enhance Public Safety by
keeping criminals off the streets
detainers are an effective tool in
keeping criminals out of local
communities by allowing ice officers to
take custody of criminal non-citizens
within the confines of a jail what is a
detainer us Immigration and Customs
Enforcement lodges detainers on
individuals who have been arrested on
criminal charges and who Isis probable
cause to believe are removable
noncitizens read that sentence again us
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
lodges detainers on individuals who have
been arrested on criminal charges and
who ice believes has probable cause to
are removable
non-citizens so they're not civil the
detainer ask the other law enforcement
agency to notify ice before a removable
individual is released from custody and
to maintain custody of the non-citizen
for a brief period of time so that ice
can take custody of that person in a
safe and secure setting upon release
from that agency's custody when law
enforcement agencies fail to honor
immigration detainers and release
serious criminal offenders into the
streets it undermines isa's ability to
protect the public safety and carry out
its mission for decades immigration
officers have used detainers as a
collaborative law enforcement tool to
request critical law enforcement
cooperation notifying ice of upcoming
release of a non-citizen who has been
arrested for a criminal viol ation
unrelated to their immigration status
underscores the importance of
information sharing between partners who
ultimately share the same goal to serve
and protect our
communities as noted above the detainer
serves as both a request for advanced
notification of release and a request to
hold the subject for a short period of
time enabling ice to take custody ice
issues detainers based on a finding by a
trained immigration officer that there
is probable cause to believe an
individual is a removable noncitizen
like all law enforcement agencies ice
considers all evidence at its disposal
to determine if probable cause for
removal exists including various
databases and electronic data probable
cause is the same legal standard that
other law enforcement agencies must meet
to make an
arrest it is important to note that not
everyone interviewed by is is detained
or removed deported everyone receives
due process and Ice focuses its
resources on removing criminals and
Public Safety threats to that end ice
collaborates with all law enforcement
agencies to help ensure that
non-citizens who may pose a public
safety threat are not released onto the
streets to reoffend and potentially harm
individuals living within our
communities however in some cases state
or local laws ordinances or policies
restrict or prohibit cooperation with
ice in other cases jurisdictions choose
to willfully decline ice detainers or
requests for notification and re release
removable non-citizens back into the
community when criminal non-citizens are
released from local or state custody
they have the opportunity to reoffend
ice must then expend additional more
extensive resources to mitigate
potential risks and make arrests in a
community
setting often ice is unable to locate a
released non-citizen before that
individual commits another crime it is
safer for everyone if ice takes custody
of a non-citizen in the controlled
environment of another law enforcement
agency as opposed to visiting a non
citizens residence place of work or
other public area arresting a criminal
in a safety security and privacy of jail
is always the best
option I feel like that pretty much
clears up what a detainer is
representative
Newman I have a question first so that
that's a pretty good description of
um the mission of of ice um what I what
I am concerned about is so they have
their request in the federal and all of
the things you
described what I didn't hear in there
was when the
local entity is going to
detain the person that what what right
do they have since I have some
information here that that detention for
48 hours is a new
arrest and it's arrest that's based upon
what that
entity has to do to do a legal arrest of
an individual so I did not hear anything
about that and uh if you if I may I'd
like to read just something that I found
on the Miami law review that talks about
that yeah sure man sure it says courts
have held that an additional 48 hour
detention constitutes a new arrest this
new arrest is a seizure under the Fourth
Amendment and thus requires independent
Authority the United States Supreme
Court in Horton versus California said
that the seizures
conducted uh outside the judicial
process without the prior approval of a
judge or magistrate are per se unre
unreasonable subject only to a few
specifically well delineated exceptions
yet this new arrest unlike a criminal
arrest violates the Fourth Amendment
when there is no judicial a warrant or
probable cause for a criminal offense
and I just believe that in there's more
to it but I'll just leave it at that and
I think that there's a potential there
that there's liability for all of these
municipalities that have put in these
laws that say they will they maybe they
will all the time but this kind of law
they've decided what they needed to do
for their community and I feel that they
face liability so I have an issue with
voting for this law thank you very much
thank you well clearly the case that you
just cited didn't go to the US Supreme
Court if it did it was struck down
because ice detainers are still
happening um second this would take any
liability away from a town because
they're following state law could I
could I just comment about that I mean
what this
says the new arrest is
a is a is a seizure under the Fourth
Amendment or so the never mind I'll take
it back I'm going yeah well know what
you're reading is a lawyer's opinion in
an article of a court opinion that we
don't know the status of or what what
hardly anything I mean but we do know
that Isis is still operating and they're
still issuing detainers so the Supreme
Court hasn't ruled that way otherwise
they wouldn't be doing that but to back
to your point about liability if the
state follow if the town or municipality
follows the state law they're not
subject to liability as long as they do
so um in a in not in a halfhazard manner
and they follow the law so they would be
have sovereign immunity based on that if
they were to set their own policy that
says we're not going to honor detainers
and they let someone out and that person
murders someone I would say they have a
greater liability there than they would
if they follow the law and hold someone
but that's well you and I can
respectfully disagree since since I
didn't realize that we be reading things
into the record but I will follow up oh
no the Supreme Court thank you
yeah sure what that means further
discussion representative Pro
I think
he oh thanks I'm out of practice um good
wait to get
him I
know um so we're only looking at felons
and nothing if they're just illegal is
their only crime
right no it doesn't talk about felons
not it just talks about what the
detainer is other words so so first of
all let me back up New Hampshire police
would only be dealing with is if they
arrested someone for a violation of New
Hampshire law they're not just going up
to people checking immigration status
you know let me check and see if there's
a detainer for you so that's clear in
here that they can only do it as part of
that second if there's a detainer in
there from Ice that means ice has
already determined this person is a
removable alien that means that they are
going back home yeah so okay thank you
yep representative
M so I I would uh urge my colleagues to
uh support uh the amendment uh it does
uh create uh a better Bill uh but I
don't believe that the amendment uh does
enough to actually address uh what I
feel are significant issues with the
bill um so uh I want to thank uh the
American civil liberties Union and the
New Hampshire immigrants rights network
uh for actually helping me draft an
alternate Amendment which we will not
see today uh that actually addresses uh
many of the problematic issues in the
bill that uh that I think we would have
supported
um in my mind that that was the start of
a possible compromise on this on this
particular bill um what the amendment
before us now uh would do is make
changes to uh one of four sections of
the bill uh it leaves uh the other four
sections in place
um the enforcement section uh is
especially problematic um during
testimony we heard uh uh from uh from
Law Enforcement Officers we got
communication from the chief of police
of Manchester from my chief of police uh
in Portsmouth that they were opposed to
this bill one of the reasons they were
opposed to it is because they feel it
will create uh additional work and force
rep
prioritization of uh some of the
activities that they officers are
engaged in and it also has potential to
create uh more liability not only for
the department but their town and I know
representative Murphy uh has some
additional information to share with us
uh on
that in terms of the changes that it
does make uh to to section three uh
removing the extremely vague language
around uh uh best efforts uh of uh Law
Enforcement Officers to comply I think
was a uh was a good start uh but
substituting it with something that's
almost as vague um uh I'm not sure
necessarily helps uh the situation at
all um we also we also have a situation
where we are once again
in enforcing inflicting whatever you
want to call it um the beliefs of what
we think and conquered on our
communities
so another way to approach this and the
way that uh we we could approach it
maybe in an alternate Amendment an
alternate universe is to actually uh
authorize towns to prohib to actually
create policies that would allow them to
do some of these things in this in this
bill so rather than uh outright prohibit
them from implementing uh Sanctuary City
policies allow them to implement
policies that um support uh some of the
objectives that are outlined in this
bill so in other words enabling
legislation that allows them to do that
uh it's it's a different approach I
think it's probably more of a New
Hampshire approach uh you know we like
to talk a lot about local control and
things like that what it does is it puts
the decision back into the hands of
communities um I think that's a
reasonable approach and uh I'm a little
disappointed that it's you know not the
approach uh we're taking and the
particular Amendment that's before us
now thank you who um Whoever has their
phone dinging if you could please mute
your phone um or whether it's a computer
whatever it is if you could just please
make sure that that volume is turned off
thank
you I didn't hear the dinging but I
heard that now I forgot what I was going
to say um I didn't listen to the okay uh
anyone else
discussion um I uh representative Balden
did I understand you
correctly um that few minutes ago you
said this only
applies to people who are charged with a
crime because did I understand that
correctly because that's not that it
does seem to be what the original Bill
intends for but not the amendment the
[Music]
um it's uh line 24 on the front page
this doesn't apply to a witness or
victim of a crime unless an immigration
detainer is on
file um and in that case an option is if
the totality of circumstances would lead
a reasonable officer to conclude the
person's release would put the public in
danger that's am I misunderstanding
that's not in the original Bill and and
it seems like the original
Bill simply doesn't apply this policy to
to
victims or Witnesses for the sake of
keeping them in the country cor yeah the
the original bill um Exempted victims
and Witnesses totally from um being
being subjected to honoring of a ice
detainer against them um and the part
that's added is that the officer has to
in other words if you have someone who's
here because they they um or someone
you're involved with in law enforcement
and they say hey I'm a witness to that
salt and Battery I saw him hit her and
there's an ice detainer on him that you
find out because when you enter
everyone's name and the Witnesses in the
computer well they would get to in the
ice detainer was because they were
wanted in bogot Columbia for murder they
would get to stay because they're a
witness to an assault and battery that's
the scales aren't very good there so
this what this does is let them look at
the totality of circumstances if
someone's wanted from by ice for murder
or one of the crimes that they would be
a witness to um a decision has to be
made and it doesn't say that they'll
turn them right over to ice I believe it
says they should contact ice and because
if you go on the ice website and I hate
referring to websites but if you go on
the ice website it says if you have an
issue with someone who's going to be a
witness call for law enforcement call us
and we'll work on it so I believe that
ice works with local law enforcement so
that they're not just taking people who
are witnesses and victims and throwing
them right out
so is it accurate that this doesn't just
apply to people who've well been
arrested because it this would mean
we're including potentially a victim of
a crime and I think the word say wanted
for
involvement which is not arrested and
it's possible they're a witness in that
situation or something right this it
sounds like you
can have um it sounds like this SE
this amendment would apply to you even
if you haven't been arrested for a
crime so the the honoring of a detainer
as far as law enforcement getting into
whether or not there's a detainer
against somebody would only be checked
if someone was arrested for a crime if
someone comes forward and they're a
victim of a crime or a witness to a
crime and during that the police
officers discover that there's an ice
detainer on them that means they're not
doing an investigation to whether this
person person is um Wanted by ice it
just comes to the police attention
because they're a victim or a witness at
that point we've that the original Bill
had an exemption where these people
could not be um or the ice detainers
would not be honored on this class of
people if they were witnesses to these
or victims of these crimes the amended
version says that if they're wanted by
ice for something that's similar to what
they're victim or witness to a
determination has to be made whether how
important they are as a victim or a
witness versus how dangerous they
released to public would be so to
clarify down what I think you're trying
to say is no it it doesn't necessarily
only apply to people who are under
arrest it this exemption was in the
original Bill I just took the exemption
said wait a minute it can't be a blanket
exemption they need to look at what the
person's wanted for so that's the change
from the original
Bill further discussion how how is it
that that the just like an example if
you could how would they determine that
there's a detainer on file if they're
not doing a search for victims or
witnesses that they're engaging with
generally speaking when the police
encounter someone and they're doing
police reports and they enter their
names into the system and they do a
wants and warrants check and it would
come up with a a a nice detainer um is
that correct uh rep represent man
yeah that could happen it it hasn't been
my practice it would have to be a triple
ey wouldn't it yeah I wouldn't run a
check on a victim or a witness to see if
they want it anywhere necessarily yeah
that generally wouldn't be my practice
Yeah so it would only be if it happened
to come to your attention somehow or
another um so in order to find that out
you'd have to actually I think run a
triple I which is a Interstate wants and
warrants check so 90% of the time this
isn't going to happen I believe that
this is here but if the person who's a
witness or a victim let's say victim of
human trafficking yeah maybe doesn't
speak English or has a certain
complexion would that motivate someone
to want to do this triple I check is it
possible that it could
be applied in a biased or presumptuous
way and also just I I'm not hearing that
this I'm not hearing any any information
contrary to the reality that this
doesn't just apply to people charged
with crimes I want to make sure I
totally understand this doesn't just
apply to people charged with crimes the
amendment no the to be very clear the
amendment does not it only applies to
people charged with crimes in so far as
honoring ice detainers this part down
here that says that an exemption for
people and other words if this person is
also a victim or a witness it will not
apply to them that's what the original
Bill said and that still applies except
for there has to be some judgment call
made as to whether or not what they're
wanted for is Worthy of saying okay you
need to stay here for this prosecution
versus turning you over to ice because
you are wanted by Ice I think that
pretty much explains it so um and with
regard to your question about
complexions and things of that nature
that would be assuming that um that
someone's racist and that they're doing
enforcing the law for racist purposes so
I can't I can't uh put my head in that
position so representative
Newman I that that just leads me it does
when a agency gets a
uh
detainer do they do they get it
primarily for someone who's incarcerated
already or are there other ways that
they get it I
mean when when I asked the questions of
the Prime sponsor I asked them how do
you how do you become come to know about
what the citizenship of the person is
and they say well they may say I'm here
I don't have a license because I'm an
illegal immigrant and and whatever so
I'd just like to clear up about how in
fact do police come to know about these
detainers that they're required to uh
deal with so when you arrest someone
generally speaking when they place under
arrest you would print their record and
it would trigger a a u a want warrant
from a federal
agency so there's no like one800 number
you can call and check and see someone's
citizenship there's there's no way for
an officer to determine someone's
citizenship unless there wanted by the
federal government otherwise there just
isn't anyway um so generally speaking
you would become aware of uh an ice
detainer once someone's already under
arrest unless they came forward
themselves and said hey I have a ice
detainer Army ice is looking for me
representative man you want to add to
that yeah I could and so if I run into
somebody um and they tell me I'm not a
citizen I'm here illegally and no ice
detainer pops up they're free to go I
don't enforce federal law so that's what
would happen and I wouldn't be inquiring
that but if they offered that
information there'd be no action that I
would take unless ice had a detainer on
them so do you have to do that in do you
have to where do you go to check that
out to see does it just come up with
like his arrest record or something like
that it comes up that there's so if
you're running the person's name if it
want a car stop or if you're arresting
somebody or whatnot it might come up
there if it's in the system through uh
through spots spots terminal which is uh
run by the state police so the state
police terminal ties into the to the
interstate um compact terminal so if
there wants out of any state in the
country when they run them generally
speaking it should pop up and that goes
for federal warrant is too so when you
run somebody it's going to pop if it's
entered so that when when that pops up
you do you do you check now then what
would he do would he he would make the
arrest at that time just because that's
there or no no he would call Immigration
first and say do you want to come get
this person and immigration would either
say yes or no if they say know you let
the person go so this would be done on
the roadside or he'd arrest him to take
him or would he just detain him to take
him to the station no I don't believe so
rep have you ever had a an ice detainer
I have not had I have not run into one
ice detainer in my career in three years
myself yeah I I I'm pretty sure that um
they would hold them on the roadside for
a few minutes it takes and and then cut
them loose because they're just being
temporarily detained until they can
ascertain the status of that so so and
they under arrest for in New Hampshire
crime they're going back to jail and
then they'll wait for the ice detainer
before they're bailed out to be uh
resolved that's what I understand and I
think even the thing that I read even
though it was only by a law school that
that the detainer there was a case and I
don't know whether it made it to the
Supreme Court but I'll check on that
yeah but that says that that when when
they just make a request to view it
hasn't been judicially reviewed so that
when they decide when a when a police
entity decides to make the arrest it has
to
be based on their issue and not
necessarily just a request from that
that at least that's my opinion thank
you very much representative wheeler
then represent Mania well I have a
question about this conversation that's
going on uh so everybody who comes here
illegally isn't necessarily issued an
ice detainer no so what is the process
by which ice issues those detainers I
think it was part of what I just read
they look at um is there a reason is the
person removable that means if they
committed a crime that would that would
justify removing them from the country
if they are removable they will put a
detainer on them then they pick them up
and I believe I believe they're entitled
to a hearing before an immigration judge
unless there's already an order to
remove in place so either way it's going
to be reviewed by immigration judge
that's what I thought I just wanted that
reinforced and then I guess you know
representative man you said you've never
faced an immigration deter you know not
once in my career I can tell you though
just to to answer representative
Newman's question technically you can
arrest on New Hampshire for violation so
if you stop some in a car for speeding
or stop sign violation technically you
can arrest them on that violation I
don't think it's ever been done but you
can do that so it's not like we're just
stopping people on the street and having
a conversation with them
and we run their name nilly Willy and it
pops up the detainer now we're Tak them
into custody just for that detainer
there would be another reason for it so
you have a a a New Hampshire law
violation that you can arrest them on um
before you be taking any action it's
been my experience and it's my
understanding that that the ice phone
number is answered promptly and they
have Regional sections and they'll say
yeah we're going to come get this guy
right away or no never mind we don't
have the staff and then you just let him
go
after you make your report saying they
told me to let them go representative
Murray thank you Mr chair um just two
points I wanted to make and this is just
from my own understanding in my Googling
on my phone during this conversation but
uh I think part of the potential concern
is that um while it seems like isce is
only issuing criminal detainers right
now I guess in the previous
administration that they also issued
civil detainers and so if this bill B
doesn't specify between civil and
criminal um that it could have a
different intended impact um than we're
talking about today um and then also
just a point that when these criminal
detainers are issued um they don't
require the same probable probable CA
standard or judicial review that a
normal arrest warrant
requires I believe didn't I just read
that it says they require probable cost
to issue a
detainer yeah pretty sure that's what I
just read from the ice website that they
have to have probable cause they
specifically said the same standard to
make an arrest um with regard to whether
or not it's a criminal or civil detainer
I do not know that that an officer can
see that um on their screen what type of
detainer it is I believe they have to
actually call to find out I don't think
it gives a lot of information about what
the detainer is for since nobody here
has seen one I don't think have you no
represent Stone the uh one involvement I
had with an ice detainer was actually
triggered from uh aphis running a set of
prints and that was on a deported felon
which means they had already been
adjudicated in our Judicial System
deported and somehow found their way
back to New Hampshire and when the
prince ran it triggered the ice
notification in the detainer and they
were within 24 hours they were there to
pick him up thank
you further discussion right
representative did you just the comment
about
oh the comment about I mean in general
there is a um a person who can be
without be undocumented in the country
and that's not a
crime because they have to have they may
have come in Legally and then overstate
it so it's a civil problem it's not a
crime it's not automatically going to
give them a detainer
right don't know depends
anyway thank
you yeah you're right that detainers
don't just
yeah in other words I think the bottom
line for this is that if there's an
detainer been
issued the immigration for wants this
person for either to be deported because
they've already done something worthy of
deportation or to question them about
something worthy of that that's a crime
um and I just read for everyone right
off this administration's and let me
tell you to represent Murray's point I
was able to dig up an archived of the
page under the previous administration
and it wasn't as friendly this one is
much more friendly and more immigrant
neutral and it it
said um I don't think it used the word
alien anywhere in it and it but it still
says the bottom line facts if someone
has a detainer it's a crime and we're
looking for them and they even go so far
as to tell people please stop making
these things that don't cooperate with
us cuz you're making it more dangerous
for us when we hear police Chiefs say I
don't want the my community to be
disturbed and uprooted by all this it's
much easier for ice to come grab someone
who's already at the police department
then for the ice to get there because
ice is notified when the name is run Hey
where's the guy you guys had oh we cut
him loose well now they have to go with
the ice team into that neighborhood and
that's really going to upset the
neighborhood so I just feel like
sometimes we we cut off our own nose to
spread our face in those situations
representative s will you raising your
hand representative janen first
yeah thank you Mr chairman I I think at
some point I know we're late in our
session but uh it might be ho us to have
uh maybe police standers and training
pull a cruiser up with the spot terminal
so we can all see what information's on
there because we talked about bail we
talked about uh domestic assault we
talked about all these other things one
of the things that I remember remember
uh when I went through that process was
if somebody's on probation or parole and
you pull them over and have an encounter
with them if they being supervised by a
probation or Pro parole officer um it'll
pop right up on the screen so if they
committed a a a petty lashy or uh some
minor crime um you immediately would
hold them for 72 hours for that
probation officer so it's not like this
is a process that's not being used in
our state
already somebody tell me if I'm wrong I
believe that's what I was told 72-hour
hold for anybody on probation parole
that's committed another crime so we're
already doing it for that I don't see
this as a big
issue um representative Shake thank you
so I I have two separate things one is
just a concern about the way in which
this bill even is amended Limits The
Power of a chief to determine how their
troops um behave at this you know when
they detain someone whether how they how
they what guidance they give and whether
it would impact their ability to
determine how their Department acts in
these situations and the other thing is
just looking at the list of things that
might exclude someone I think about
someone who might have been the key
witness in a really horrific crime um
and maybe they were involved in another
crime in their previous country because
maybe they were forced into a drug
cartel as a 12-year-old and you know as
a result of fleeing their country to get
out of that lifestyle are now here are
wanted for things in their home country
for whatever reason but now they've been
a witness to a major crime here and and
by contacting ice we've now first of all
disincentivized them from coming forward
to speak about what they've witnessed
and and testifying against the
perpetrator of a violent crime here and
we've also um potenti ually lost them to
ice to be you know dealt with however so
that that crime ultimately is not
prosecuted and the victims of those
crimes remain um un uncared for that's
not the right word but
unsatisfied thank you um in response to
your first
point unfortunately or or or fortunately
actually more fortunately um towns and
cities and municipalities don't have
walls around them and you know we are
local control State sometimes but we are
a Dylan's R State and when something
doesn't affect your neighbors local
control makes sense but when something
you do affects the your neighbors in the
entire State that's not local control so
a town saying we're not going to arrest
people who may be dangerous or we're
going to let people who may be dangerous
go that town doesn't keep them only in
their borders so saying well a chief
locally can't decide for his own town
well he's not he's deciding for the
whole state because that person is free
to move about the state um and secondly
with regard to we do have in here that
the people um the agencies will work
with Federal immigration authorities to
help ensure the availability of the
person to participate in the prosecution
of the State Crime Isis indicated that
they will work with um they don't just
fly right in and grab people out if
they're part of a crime they'll work
with the Attorney General's office uh on
allowing that person to testify and
things of that nature they may even be
able to work something out regarding the
their their um status as being deported
um but at the at the end of the day you
know you've said that well what if they
were did a crime in their home country
because you know they were forced into
it on the other side of that coin we
have the the the mass murderer and Ry
who committed crimes in his State as
part of some kind of corrupt government
scheme I think from what I read so you
don't know we don't know so we can't we
have to first thing we have to do is
protect our citizens representative
wheeler thank you Mr chairman and this
doesn't ban
uh you know Peter bro has I think an
ordinance or warrant article that says
that we're a welcoming Community it's
very Broad and the police chief still
works with the federal that does this
does not ban uh those kind of Warren
articles it's only if uh municipality is
refusing to comply with ice in the
federal government that's really all it
does you can be welcoming you can help
people get um Services you can help
people find housing this has nothing to
do with what you as a community want to
do except for unless you want to let
people go who are wanted by the federal
government so all the churches that are
doing the great work that came and said
that they were doing the great work
would impact them whatsoever absolutely
and the Immigrant communities that are
here are still going to be able to and
it seems to me like uh to bring up
representative selig's uh Point um that
somebody in that situation would still
be eligible for Asylum if they were if
they were wanted for for crimes or if
they were wanted by uh gang members in
you know say Nicaragua or one of the
South American countries than than that
is is uh eligible for Asylum as far as
the Asylum courts would go and that this
wouldn't apply to that person I
anticipate we're going to see a lot of
those from Haiti very soon if not
already so um you in a second um
representative
Elber thank you Mr chair uh I am
wondering what the concerns you
had uh with the amendment filed by
representative Muse that let you to
decide that you wanted to have a
different one there's some significant
overlaps and also some significant
differences significant departures um
and I I did read the amendment and I
chose not to recognize the amendment
because it um it it totally undid
everything really in my opinion what the
bill was trying to do by allowing it um
to be by allowing it to be a decision in
other words we're saying you can't make
this decision in the bill but that
Amendment kind of says well you can kind
of make that decision it just goes about
it a different way um so I chose that to
not entertain that one um representative
Balden I think
[Music]
um in regard to representative Wheeler's
question
the there are sections of the bill
unaffected by this amendment that say no
state government entity local government
entity or law enforcement agency shall
knowingly enact issue adop prom
promulgate M enforce permit endorse
maintain or having any in effect any
Sanctuary policy and Sanctuary policy is
defined as law policy practice procedure
custom
I'm not sure that it is the case that
Peterboro could
continue portraying itself as a
welcoming keep reading you didn't finish
reading your sentence it says is adopted
or Allowed by a state entity or local
government which prohibits or impedes
law enforcement agency from complying
with 8 USC 1373 which prohibits imped
law enforcement agency from
communicating and cooperating it make
sense that a custom that
impedes uh enforcement might be being a
welcoming town no that's a stretch I
think I don't think so but um I'm just
the this I stopped reading the news a
long time ago so I don't know about this
Mass killer but if that's one person
what do we do with the far more than one
person being human trafficked in the
state of New Hampshire who is here um
illegally and doesn't want to be here um
they would have detainer but is
terrified of we don't know why they
might or might not have an A detainer
that's what I'm saying is that this
seems like it does nothing for Vic
victims of human trafficking nothing to
encourage them to call and all that it
does
is set the ex expectation and the
standard that people who are brought
here against their will who are being
human trafficked who are being raped
shouldn't engage with law enforcement in
any capacity and I it's just weird to me
because we've passed other laws in this
legislature in recent years to for
example
encourage people voluntarily engaging in
sex work in the state of New Hampshire
unrelated to ice or immigration or
anything just everyday Granite Staters
um that if they're the victim of a crime
they should be able to report that crime
to police without fear of arrest why
aren't we going to give people
victimized through human trafficking the
same
benefit it's not the same benefit um
someone who's involved in prostitution
calling to say that they've been abused
so that they're not in fear of arrest of
being prosecuted for
prostitution is nowhere near the same as
saying to someone who's here illegally
we will not honor this ice detainer on
you that says that you've committed a
crime that makes you removable from this
country those two are not equal in any
kind of way and furthermore if someone
is being trafficked um ice itself has
programs to help them but what we can't
do is say to ourselves you're setting
ice up as some kind of evil entity that
we mustn't cooperate with we mustn't
tell them what's going on we mustn't
share information with them they're the
bad guys setting up the Federal
immigration as as an evil entity and
where the good guys are going to protect
you from them is a horrible precedent um
to say that to our citizens that well we
trust them sometimes sometimes we don't
I mean um either we Mr chair I'm not
sure I would um you're kind of be saying
that motivation what a motivation of
another speaker is I don't I'm telling
you exactly what I heard I heard that we
speak to representative Roy motives
later on something else TI for Tat but
yeah but but what I'm saying is if
you're being human trafficked and you're
in the state of New Hampshire and you're
aware of people being um removed from
the country due to immigration status
and you don't even know where your
passport is because it was stolen from
you are you going to engage with law
enforcement to try to save your own life
and the life of the people that are
being trafficked with you mhm I highly
doubt that that's the function of
denying them the ability to access their
own legal documents so I think that this
sends a terrible message to victims of
human trafficking and potentially
emboldens human
traffickers perhaps I think we're going
to have to disagree um I just don't see
it that way I see it as um protecting
our own citizens and we can't be held
hostage by human traffickers who are we
have to just not check anybody's status
because they might be human literally
there's people being held hostage by
human traffickers I know there are we as
a committee we could join in and also be
held hostage as you're saying and at
least stand with people being human
trafficked and encourage them to engage
with law enforcement so that they can be
rescued and the people controlling their
bodies can be held to account but this
seems to send us in the opposite
direction where we're driving a wedge
between victims and police where they
don't want to cooperate I disagree um
representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman how much experience do you have
with the Immigrant Community do you um
do volunteer work or are these all
hypothetical situations that are holding
up everybody's time thank
you is that directed at me
exclusively
CH Meo yeah so I have a lot of
experience thank you
englishan is that experience we can all
speak a different language we won't know
the hell's going on representative go
ahead representative I would also like
to that question was out of line go
ahead what I just want to note um in
light of kind of this this conversation
here is that
um policies like this make it so that
you do not speak in specifics because if
you speak in specifics about your
specific uh exper experience or an
individual uh experience with an
individual who may be put in that
situation you put that person in danger
so I just want to call that out because
uh it's very difficult to have a
conversation and speaking about specific
stories or even being able to engage
with people who may be able to help that
person all right and so I I'm going to
put out a hypothetical because I can't
possibly um uh endanger someone uh whose
whose uh situation I been entrusted with
okay so like there yes there are many
situations you cannot speak specifically
about them particularly and specifically
because things like this make you afraid
that in speaking about them specifically
you are going to put them in danger I'm
not entirely sure what you just said but
I think I think you meant that you uh
she's using hypotheticals because if she
said a specific case it would put
somebody in danger and I don't think
that's what the question was out of
order anyway representative um Muse I'm
about to um call the unless you have
something very important to say I think
we've beaten this pretty
much I just wanted to say that you know
I I just want to acknowledge this is a a
super complicated issue with a lot of
implications for law enforcement with uh
implications for our immigrant Community
um it it's
complicated and and I just think it's
important for us to go um not only on
the best information we have but on on
accurate information so on the on the
ice website um essentially what it says
is a detainer uh isn't probable cause
that a crime has been committed and I'll
read you exactly what they say ice
issues detainers based on a finding by a
trained immigration officer that there
is probable cause to believe an
individual as a removable
noncitizen it's not probable cause that
they created murder or they created or
that they that they committed a crime
it's probable caused by an immigration
officer not a judge that they're in the
country
illegally that that is what the a
detainer is so there have been you know
a lot of our conversation has involved
equivocating uh detainers with things
like arrest warrants from out of States
other states this this really is a
different animal and and I think it's
something that is important enough to be
approached more carefully than we're
approaching it in this bill the
amendment it's not that there isn't
anything here that's worth doing I think
there absolutely is I think that it
would be a great thing if we had
clarification for our communities
clarification for law enforcement and
clarification on these issues for
immigrant communities I just don't think
that this is the way to do
it the motion on the floor is out to
pass I ask the CL call the
rooll amended on the amendment no
actually yeah we've been talking so long
I don't know what we're doing um I would
just say I was adopt the
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative
Pratt yes representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
Hill yes representative Muse yes
representative Rosner yes representative
Balden yes representative elberger yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
S no uh yes sorry yes representative
wheeler yay chairman re chair yes 20 20
the motion to adopt the amendment is uh
the motion is adopted I make a motion of
ought to pass as amended second seconded
I'm not going to speak to the motion I
think we all know where we stand on this
um do you want to speak to the mo your
second anyone else wish to speak that
hasn't spoken already seeing none the
motion on the floor is out to pass with
Amendment representative roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
Hill yes representative muse no
representative Rosner no representative
Balden no Representative elberger no
representative Murphy no representative
Newman no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
sing No representative
wheeler yay um chairman Roy chal yes 119
119 motion carries um anything that we
pass today um or we don't pass we need
the reports today um today is the
deadline so um representative Muse will
you be doing The Minority
Report yes I will thank you today before
you go please um let me see with that I
close the executive session on House
Bill
563 and I open the executive session on
House Bill
578 and I recognize representative rhs
to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move
interim study for um how uh Senate Bill
578 second
second speak to your motion oh thank you
Mr Mr chairman
um this uh particular Bill if I'm not
mistaken had to do with uh the
monitoring of of prechal services and
this was something that was covered
extensively in the bail package that the
um our friends have that they are voting
on now and it is the hope that they will
pass that bill as written because all of
these other bail bills have been
addressed in
that thank you represent Manion do you
want to speak to you a second no thank
you she's cover it yeah um I would just
tell everyone this is again another bail
bill that we spent all last summer
working on and we've sent over already
further comment discussion seeing none
the motion on the floor is um internal
study Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative
PR oh
sorry um representative jandrin yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative
Hill yes representative Muse yes
Rosner yes representative Balden yes
representative elberger yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
salig yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 190 190 the
motion of inter study passes I here I
close the executive session I open the
executive session on Senate
bill which one are we
on
591 and
you going have a
that you want to do
that yes I I move OTP I
second would you like to speak to your
motion I would um I actually have a
statement that I wanted to make just
some comments um in in support of this
bill um as someone formerly employed by
New Hampshire DCF I follow the that YDC
case closely and I'm appalled as I think
we all should be by the level of abuse
that was allowed to go on there I'm
profoundly saddened by the trauma that
these victims experience as a result of
both the abuse and the court action that
followed there will forever be a black
mark on the state of New Hampshire for
its failure to protect over a thousand
of our most vulnerable citizens despite
their pleas for help and the protection
that they most assuredly deserved and
should have been able to expect
knowing that there's no amount of money
that will give these victims their lives
back who they would have been had they
not been repeatedly victimized while in
state custody supporting this
legislation while an attempt to protect
the financial health of the State of New
Hampshire does little really to truly
compensate these individuals and nothing
to ensure that this never happens again
that said I recognize and appreciate the
efforts of all who've worked um to come
to some level of agreement to provide
what victims likely still feel is it
woeful y inadequate compensation I will
vote OTP in support of compensation
efforts and look forward to learning
more about the policy changes that will
prevent a travesty like this from ever
happening
again thank you I uh Second and concur
any further
discussion see none motion is ought to
pass I ask the clerk to call the
role Vice chair Roes yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative crew yes representative
jenan yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative Hill yes
representative Muse yes representative
Rosner yes representative Balton yes
representative elberger yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the Clark votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sing representative wheeler yay chairman
Roy chair votes yes 20 20 motion not to
pass any objection consent seeing none
we're going
consent executive session is
closed we're going to take a 10 bio
break
for
e
e e
do you wish to speak to your motion
shortly this bill um will give us a
report to make sure that in the future
we uh release videotapes of uh police
War cameras in the proper manner uh
there is a proper way of doing it and an
important reason for both sides to have
the information but uh there's concern
about it getting online or out of the
proper hands so this report would be
very
important would you like to speak to you
a second no thank you Mr chairman
represent wheeler thank you Mr chairman
the only thing I would really quickly
have to add is for the record I hope
that we next year would be able to come
back and update the body camera statute
so that defense Council are able to uh
make sure that they have that for their
trials yeah I I think an important thing
about this um bill is by the time we get
to the legislation next year that this
is going to drive where all the other
people get to weigh in well law
enforcement won't be having to think
about it we've already got their
position so now we can focus on you know
what the ACLU position is the defense
Council position is law enforcement will
have laid their position in stone so we
know what it is um did you have your
hand up representative man yes thank you
so
I I may have told this before this is in
my wheelhouse this is what I currently
do in my capacity as a la officer is
body cameras so when I first saw the law
I thought this wasn't written by police
officers it's it's it's just all over
the place um there is case law now aomar
Amic Superior Court saying that you must
provide a hard copy to defense so that's
being done I understand the concern is
is what's being done with it after that
because we can't monitor it we can't
prevent it from being released on
YouTube there has to be something to put
in place so I think there's a lot of
work that has to be done with the
statute it has some issues with it and I
think having a law
enforcement um voice in it to to to
draft some legislation is a good idea
and then it will come probably back to
this body for all of us to weigh in on
it thank you yeah absolutely it will and
and to your point about the case law
it's not a good thing when the court has
to torture itself around our statutes to
do the right thing so we need to let
them untwist that knot they've made and
and let it be in statute that they can
provide that representative sake thank
you I just want to say I think having
more data is a good thing and having
clear and specific data allows us to
make the most informed decisions which
is crucial agreed and we may not agree
with the law enforcement position but at
least we'll know what it is when it gets
here representative zitec uh Mr chairman
I came in late for the U the that
testimony did merac County weigh were
they in favor of this bill they were um
they would have liked to see it go a
little further but they said it's a good
start
and representative M yeah one thing I
wanted to point out is the effective um
the the date that the report is actually
due is November 1st
2024 um if you're familiar with our bill
filing deadlines in the house um those
can be kind of all over the place
sometimes well before that date um
sometimes not too long afterwards so
even in a best case scenario situation
it doesn't allow um much time to have uh
legislation drafted and to actually get
that kind of input once this committee
makes a recommendation so I I'll support
the bill because I think it's it's good
work to do but um I would encourage um
uh Lea to make their report uh available
well before the 1 of
November thank you um and as a member of
that commission I will take that to them
and let them know that they if they want
this input to be taken and I would also
encourage someone if they want to file a
bill and we'll fill in the blanks with
this when we get it representative s
thank thank you just to that point my
understanding is the Senate's deadlines
are later so um maybe the intent is that
the Senate would be the one to provide
the bill for quite possibly yeah either
or we'll figure out a way representative
scitec just asking but uh can't you
introduce the non gerain Amendment
anytime absolutely you can if that those
don't necessarily go always the way you
want but yes we could if we were to find
another bill um representative Murphy
thank you I actually just have a
question about the fiscal note um I'm
not sure if the fiscal note is was for
as introduced or because it talks about
it requires an additional full-time
position and I don't does that it sounds
like it was as introduced because it I
believe it was changed just to make this
uh be assigned to Lee act for their
drafting purpos yeah that that that
wouldn't apply to the amended version of
the bill because they don't have the
ability to have a full-time person or
just a commission so I don't I believe
that was probably the original fiscal no
thank you okay with that I would ask
clerk to call the RO the motion of floor
is ought to
pass Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative citech te
representative PR yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative Hill yes
representative Muse yes representative
Rosner yes representative Bon yes
representative elberger yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sing yes and representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 20
motion about to pass carries any
objection consent seeing none close the
executive session um Senate Bill 508 I'm
moving to next Wednesday there will be a
non- gerain Amendment hearing on that
and with that I open the executive
session on Senate Bill
248 and I
recognize representative rhs to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move uh
in terms study for Senate Bill
248 I second that would you like to
speak to your motion uh basically this
is a another another bail bill that uh
the hopefully the concerns that are in
this in this legislation have been
addressed in the bill that um our
friends have and hopefully they'll do
the right thing with those bills
today I second that um I'm quite sure
it's in the thing that we we already
sent them because we covered absolutely
everything um any further discuss
discussion seeing none I ask clerk to
call the rooll the motion on the floor
is inter room
study Vice chair Roose representative
Pratt yes representative saitech yes
representative PR yes representative
jenin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative Hill yes
representative Muse yes representative
Rosner yes representative Balon yes
representative elberger yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair vot yes 20 20 motion
of interim study passes any objection to
consent seeing none close the executive
session we are now done till next
Wednesday thank you everyone I know
today was pretty contentious on some of
the bills but no one seems to be
bleeding so that's always a good sign
representative s thank you um just I
passed out thinking we were going to get
to it an amendment for five
that is a Germain amendment that
corrects language so if everybody could
make sure to keep their copy safe
because um I passed them all out the
non- Germain Amendment we're going to
hear does not affect the underlying bill
so it will go as planned I just want to
make sure people keep the copy because
they're they're distributed keep your
keep your copies all right I'll see you
guys all next
Wednesday now we don't we don't have
anything scheduled Friday do
we
today as soon as you can can um I'm not
leaving till I do mine so Mr chairman if
I may remember reports are due today
everyone if you if you're doing a report
look at Brad see him nodding yes they
have to go to the clerk today right so
248 uh 362 563 591
like as soon as absolutely possible uh
248 is me um 591 I believe is
representative Murphy um 362
who's
362 um 362 is representative
Pratt all right that's and then 563 is
you
actually e